hello let's talk religion before we
start any kind of discussion on this
channel we should probably get rid of
the elephant in the room I mean if we're
going to talk about religion that we
should probably all agree on how to
define the word itself right well turns
out that's a very difficult thing to do
when by the end of this video you might
just be more confused and you were going
in which I guess in a way defeats the
purpose really but anyway I should point
out that there's a great video on this
very subject over on the religion for
breakfast channel and it's actually
really good so after you watch this one
you should go and give him some love as
well I'll leave a link in the
description okay so in the academic
study of religions we paradoxically used
the word religion with great caution one
of the first thing we learn when we
study religion is that there is no
official definition for the word and you
can obnoxiously type in some definition
that you've heard or say that our
religion is opium for the masses but the
fact remains that there is no official
definition for the word that doesn't
mean the people haven't tried however
for example Edward B Taylor who is
considered one of the founders of
anthropology the defined religion as
belief in supernatural beings and this
is of course a rather narrow and
specific definition for the word that
also leaves out a lot of what we would
call religion today
another example is by Clifford Geertz
who has a much more broad definition for
the word he writes that religion is a
system of symbols which acts to
establish powerful pervasive and
long-lasting moods and motivations in
men by formulating conceptions of a
general order of existence and clothing
these conceptions with such an aura of
factuality that the moods and motivation
seems uniquely realistic now these
obviously are two very different ideas
about what religion is and who's to say
that one is more right or wrong than the
other
even if these two individuals are
greatly admired and followed by modern
anthropologists everyone still creates
their own image and idea of what
religion is in other ways we create
our own field so to say consider this
painting for example is this religion or
is it arts if your answer is that it's
both then which part of it is religion
and which part of it is arts can you
divide it up into these two categories
it kind of blends together doesn't it I
think we would all agree that
Christianity is a religion right but is
Scientology religion is Jediism a
religion is football a religion even it
all depends on how you define the word
religion itself many scholars have tried
to get to the bottom of the question of
religion especially in the last century
or so and there are a lot of conflicting
opinions about what sort of the
underlying causes of it are for example
Emile Durkheim is one of the champions
of a sociological explanation for
religion and he argues that the idea of
society is the soul of religion to him
religion is a set of practices and
symbols that work mainly towards social
cohesion much like a nation's flag
religion becomes a symbol for a certain
group of people and a kind of uniting
principle he studied Australian tribes
and so-called simple peoples basically
people that live like we would imagine
people lived thousands of years ago and
he studied totem culture and told him
religion in these tribal cultures in
these studies he shows that different
totems represent different tribes or
different groups and is also worshipped
by those same groups by extension they
are worshipping themselves or more
specifically the tribe to which they
belong and Durkheim extends this idea to
other religions and behavior outside
religion as well so for example if you
have a nation like the u.s. there are
certain symbols that come to mind like
the flag with with the stars a hamburger
maybe or a bald eagle and now the bald
eagle for instance becomes a symbol for
the US and for American patriotism
religions to Durkheim works the same way
except it is the god or the deity or
whatever it is that becomes that uniting
and symbolic principle that that the
group can sort of unite under another
well-known theory is a more
psychological perspective
by people like Sigmund Freud who argued
that religion is a faulty sense of
security for people much like a teddy
bear for a child and that we should get
rid of that teddy bear even compares
religion to certain mental illnesses and
argues that quote religion is comparable
to childhood neuroses he didn't like
religion very much these are just a few
examples of the ideas and theories on
the origin and explanation for religion
but there's a problem all of these
individual scholars academics have one
thing in common and that is that they
are all Western scholars working
primarily from a European or American
framework about things like what even
religion means and this is very
problematic in fact a very term religion
as we know it was probably conceived of
in this particular region in Europe in
America and only in the last few
centuries or so let me explain if I were
to ask you what the most central aspect
of religion is the core principle
throughout religion chances are you
would answer that it deals with faith or
some kind of belief or belief system and
if this is your answer then you're
probably from a Western Protestant
Christian culture in fact the idea of
religion is primarily faith is a very
Protestant idea and if you were to ask a
Hindu or a Muslim from India the same
question chances are they would give you
a lot different answers perhaps they say
religion is about a practice or certain
behavior or family even is a very good
example for this phenomenon and one that
my old teacher used to bring up all the
time so I'm from Sweden right and we
like to consider ourself sort of
secularized or not very religious in his
example he always brings up that in a
lot of cases when people come from other
parts of the world to Sweden they are
amazed to find out how religious we are
and now you may be confused and ask well
how are we religious well according to
them we take care of the elderly we
treat each other well we have a good
welfare system these kinds of things
which shows that to them religion is
completely different
their definition then what some of ours
maybe we think about belief in a God we
think about going to church they think
about welfare and taking care of the
elderly so completely different ideas
about what being religious means in fact
many argue that religion as we
understand it in the West is very much
based on Christianity and the templates
that Christianity contains because when
the Christian empires conquer the world
they often took very complex local
systems and traditions and placed the
label of religion on them you know that
thing that Christianity is only not as
good as an example of this you can just
look at the education about religion in
Europe and the textbooks that are given
to the students in them all religions
are often divided into three categories
according to a scholar who uses these a
lot of the time and these three
categories are the man the text and the
faith sound familiar
well this is because this is a Christian
template there is Jesus the man the
Bible the text and the Christian faith
the Christian theology that that the
core of Christianity the problem arrives
when I try to forcibly apply these
categories to other religions as if they
were the same when they are clearly not
the same even a closely related religion
like Islam when you put these categories
it is the man which becomes Mohammed the
text the Quran and the Muslim faith the
Muslim theology but the Quran is not
just the Muslim Bible the Quran has a
much different role and position within
Islam than the Bible has in Christianity
and Muhammad has a much different role
in Islam than Jesus has in Christianity
so to say that things like what the
Quran equals the Muslim Bible is very
problematic and that undermines the
complexity and an difference of of all
these traditions that were trying to
educate and study to further destroy an
idea of what religion is is to talk
about the apparent difference between
religion and the rest of society so let
me explain in the West today we have
certain category certain pockets of our
lives so there's politics there
sports there is culture and there's
religion and all these occupy their own
parts of our lives even if they blend
together sometimes but again this is a
very modern and Western perspective on
it this has not always been the case and
in a lot of parts of the world it still
isn't the case previously in history and
indeed in parts of the world still today
all these categories tended to blend
together it was all just part of life
religion didn't have its own place that
you could choose to approach or ignore
it was just there infinitely fused into
all aspects of life and love society but
this also means that our societies are a
lot more religious or affected by
religion than we tend to believe again
in Sweden we consider ourselves to be
very secular we have separated church
and state for example and and so on but
we don't realize how Christian we really
are everything about our culture just
fumes with Christianity our flag has a
cross on it we have our weekends on
Sundays and Saturdays we tend to believe
that religion is primarily about faith
or belief and our entire moral compass
is based on Christianity every part of
our society is in one way or another at
least partly influenced by the Christian
tradition to elaborate one of the most
famous scholars of religion Talal Asad
argues that there can be no distinction
between culture and religion in a famous
essay called the construction of
religion as an anthropological category
he argues that religion as a phenomenon
separated from politics law and science
have emerged from a unique Western
post-reformation history in other words
religion cannot be separated from
culture or any of the other categories
mentioned above as this is a construct
by the West and made to benefit the
Western or Christian worldview well not
everyone agrees with Assad and certainly
I think there is some value in using the
word religion his idea certainly point
to the fact that these lines between a
lot of these subjects are often very
fuzzy and
and really undefined of course our
discipline is called comparative
religion after all so the word obviously
means something you can even argue that
all religions around the world have
something in common that makes them
religions but this is also a very
dangerous path filled with snakes and
sharks and killer whales that will kill
you and play with your dead body it is
after all a word that exists for a
reason and it kind of means something I
mean if I say the word religion most of
you know at least somewhat what I'm
talking about and to sit here and try to
define words until they no longer mean
anything is to me just counterproductive
and I argue that we should use this word
both in conversation and as an academic
concept we should do so with great
caution and have all these things that
I've talked about in mind it is useful
as an analytical tool but it's also very
dangerous term and it tries to encompass
a whole lot I would argue that this is
religion versus religion this is
religion this is religion as well but
also this this and this religion says we
understand them exists all around the
world and in countless different forms
they can serve as justification for
terrible things but also of wonderful
and beautiful things if we accept a
broad definition of religion it
encompasses an almost endless number of
things but that's also what makes it so
interesting I'll see you next time
[Music]